okay so hundred days boy the press loves
that benchmark I guess it means
something and let me just ask about this
tax plan before we get into the details
the one-page thing they had a hundred
days what happened during the first
ninety nine and a half days apparently
they did not study it's like a kid who
forgot to do the assignment yeah and
wrote it on the bus on the way to school
these are supposedly smart Jews and
Goldman Sachs and this is you have a you
have a group of people who have no idea
how to govern they don't understand
public policy they don't understand how
this country interacts with the rest of
the world there are people that have
never held these jobs who most from the
for the most part want to destroy the
very agencies that they're that they're
representing so there was an are not
Islander why this happened in Politico I
know who this is but they're quoting a
senior White House official who said I
kind of poo pooed the experience stuff
when I first got here but this is
hard and he didn't mean that he needed a
stool softener he met
he meant that the work itself was hard I
do drawings of my get it I'm sorry bill
wait it's not I'm sorry I'm here go
ahead
no I saw that and I thought to myself
what the hell you people been doing this
whole time for those of us who have been
involved in politics who have worked on
Capitol Hill like I have who have been
in government understand how things work
what work whether it's on a local level
or not how do you not know the enormity
of the White House and the fact that
there's so many people that have
surrounded Trump it's bad enough that he
didn't know what the hell he was doing
but he surrounded himself with people
who didn't know what the hell they were
doing and now here we are I promise to
going around saying I had no idea I miss
my old life and you know like he's in
over a comb-over get it in maybe how so
many the Republicans are on our side yes
because you know oh do you this is like
you know but it's like in mine and we
all you have to do is stick your trouble
in and it just rains go I mean for you
guys it's like yeah I mean it's a good
and bad you know we love that you can
get those lessons you're the best at it
but it's also an old route of the entire
country and you know it's not so much a
plan is a cliche what would really
struck me is it was like they
photocopied talking points from the
Heritage Foundation it's just no I don't
I don't like real poverty because if
service actors not have it here in the
clinic in my head
one thing the mercy these things it says
grow the economy and create millions of
jobs magic
Jaka
yeah simplify our burdensome tax code as
if the Americans can't distinguish
between three and seven think about the
tax break yeah it's just so a lot first
of all we need more tax bracket yeah
less yes the idea that someone who pays
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
that's the highest bracket also pays the
same as someone who makes ten billion
yeah right
that's proposal ERISA Posterous okay are
you gonna I would even say that we could
discuss having a flat tax with no no no
I don't you got it like we do provided
package owners need to tell me that that
the American will need to simplify the
tax code for them amuse imaginary case
has been passed world without not
getting joy about what tax flat tax is
another giant giveaway to the rich
people why do you want to do that well
it depends on items and it's a fairly
great your rich person I'm far from rich
I'm number wasn't benefit and you guys
are out yeah I'll probably pour it okay
right now on right from the rich guy
[Applause]
like are any more money we live in
America like for you I would be I think
if that is all that this is not paid for
and it's going to blow the mother of all
holes yeah I'm in debt what come on
Republicans I think I see a pattern here
they run up everything on the credit
card they could get a about
spending when they're in office as soon
as the Democrat takes over what we don't
have any money anywhere the Democrats
seem to take over and then it's up to
them to put the house back in order